Shazam!
my son dreamt of a better
world that's why he saved me
the hero
i just got goosebumps
come with us
it's a glorious world out there
waiting for you
Welcome back everyone this will be my black
adam trailer video we totally smell what the
rock is cooking there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs here they also changed up what's happening
with dc movies this year i'll explain what's
going on with that what the release schedule
is during the video too if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos when we get a little bit closer
i will do a ticket giveaway for the actual movie
they wound up delaying all the dc movies by a
couple months and switching around some of the
later ones because they finished filming aquaman 2
really late in the timeline and they weren't going
to have enough time to finish special effects so
they needed like an extra couple months for that
so instead of swapping some of the other movies
they just delayed everything by a couple months
to give everybody a couple extra months to do
special effects and they bumped up shazam too
so we're actually getting shazam 2 at the end of
the year i think it actually makes more sense to
have the black adam movie in the shazam 2 movie
really close together because even though they're
not going to be a ton of crossover between those
two movies like they have to set up black adam for
the first time in that first black adam movie and
then the plot of shazam 2 fury of the gods is all
about them fighting a version of the gods family
where they get some of their powers from like the
shazam acronym is a bunch of the gods that they
draw their power from they're fighting the family
of one of those gods atlas we'll probably get some
sort of post credit scene in either black adam or
in shazam 2 that will tease their big crossover
with shazam versus black adam and that'll happen
in like the next movies after these two movies
don't worry you're going to get to see black adam
pound the shazamly something fierce naturally
you see black adams powers and they're meant
to look very similar to shazam's powers because
they all draw their power from the same place
even the shazam characters got costume upgrades
to make their costume look closer to black adam's
costume like they all got upgrades all around but
obviously they want all their costumes black adam
and the shazamly costumes to look similar because
all their powers come from the same place the only
real difference between black adam and the other
shazam characters is black adam doesn't share
his ability the way that the shazam character
shares his ability with the rest of the shazamly
that's why in a one-on-one fight black adam can
totally beat the crap out of shazam it's when the
entire shazamly fights black adam that's when
he's in trouble if he fought them all one at a
time it'd be like that funny video the person
going around slapping everyone one at a time
larry what the hell are you doing sorry barrett
you can't just oh lovely oh are you all right
the whole thing in the black adam movie obviously
is just establishing the justice league inside the
dceu establishing who black adam is because he's
usually portrayed as an anti-hero like he's kind
of a villain but he also helps the heroes at times
and the reason why they're going with the justice
society instead of the traditional justice league
is because most the time in the comics black adam
has been associated more with the justice society
characters also they're trying to introduce as
many new groups inside the dc eu as possible and
this is meant to be connected to the traditional
dceu the justice league line of movies i
know there's always a question about what's
continuity what's not continuity what's going on
with the multiverse because in the flash movie
everything is supposed to become candid through
the multiverse the same way that they just did
in doctor strange too i could do this all day
i understood that reference i know you're all
asking who the actual villain is in the black
adam movie because we don't really see him that
much they kind of hint at what's going on with
the villain because they want somebody to come
off as black adam you have to have somebody who's
even worse supposedly the villain in the film is
going to be the sabacc character who's a demon in
the comics and the way they're playing him in the
character is that it's actually going to be like
a human avatar who has very shazam similar powers
only they come from a demon instead of the way the
shazam characters and black adam get their powers
from gods in the trailer footage where you see
this floating crown inside a tomb that's meant to
be the crowd of sabok it's supposed to hold some
special power that the villain is trying to obtain
that will help turn him into this crazy op big
bad that the rest of the justice league even black
adam will have trouble fighting and his forces
are essentially just destroying the entire region
around conduct and that's why black adam wants to
kill him and get rid of him which is a very comic
book thing black adam basically getting rid
of the current leadership in conduct and then
taking over rulership himself which is why you
don't see him interacting with a lot of justice
league characters because he spends most of
his time ruling over his country of conduct
you see a bunch of footage of hawkman in his
stanigarian nth metal armor and some of his
abilities all these interiors of the ship here
with all this technology that's all meant to be
thanegarian technology the younger characters are
meant to be cyclone and adam smasher i think adam
smasher is going to be like one of the subsequent
versions of the character because his costume
looks very old-timey like it's old tech that he
just picks up and uses supposedly because they're
very long-lived hawkman and dr fate used to be on
this old version of the justice society something
really went off the rails with their team a bunch
of them died they're the only survivors in present
day and then the newer members come onto the
team and they sort of reform this new version
so i believe this part of the trailer where
they're sitting in the chair and they're talking
about how cool this is all going to be everything
is so weird that's inside the justice society's
mansion they'll probably be a bunch of easter
eggs for that old version of the team if they
don't have a ton of flashbacks like all these
artifacts inside the justice society's mansion
they do kind of have a version of the justice
society on the star girl tv show and they kind
of tease the similar thing too where they go
to this old mansion that used to be the justice
society's headquarters and they have all these
old artifacts of former team members and you have
this whole idea with hawkman and dr fate trying
to get black adam's help because it looks like
sarah shahi's character who's going to be playing
a version of his love interest from the comics
you all know who i'm talking about youtube
has a weird thing about saying her name
because they completely confuse it with the big
terrorist group but that's who she's playing she's
the person who frees black adam inside this tomb
it's the prison that the wizard shazam trapped
him in 5 000 plus years ago when he went off the
rails you get a little bit of his backstory like
they kind of explained why it is that he went so
crazy and i think in service of portraying him as
more of an anti-hero the way they'll explain it in
this movie is that you didn't get the whole story
like the wizard shazam told the story about how
they chose wrongly and he freed the seven deadly
sins and all these people wound up dying the way
they explained it in some of the other trailers
that they've released is that in the past black
adam was born into slavery and it looks like
they wind up killing his family in front of his
eyes and that sort of drives him mad however they
explain it in this movie he winds up gaining
the powers of shazam there's a bit of trickery
in the way that he gains the powers in the comics
like he kind of steals the powers of shazam
but he sees his family die he wants revenge and
he sees all this terrible stuff happening so he
wants to get rid of all these people and it sounds
like the seven deadly sins take advantage of that
and convince him to free them and they're
the ones that wind up killing everybody
and black adam doesn't really care that much about
the collateral damage like he's just happy to kill
the people who he thought were responsible for
the death of his family and i believe during the
movie version what they're gonna say is it's
the seven deadly sins who wound up killing
the council of wizards who were ruling in the
rock of eternity except for the wizard shazam
like he survived and then trapped black adam to
prevent something like that from happening again
but all the indiana jones stuff that you see going
on in the characters the reason why they would
be looking around all these ancient tombs in this
area is because they are looking for the crown of
sabac they're not specifically looking for black
adam himself he just also happens to be nearby in
tying this to black adam versus superman because
the rock has been trying to do a black adam versus
superman project for so long it just sounds like
there's so much going on in this movie i don't
expect a ton of superman in it for those of you
wanting henry cavill to come back as superman this
is like the best shot for it the rock has so much
power relative to the black adam character that he
can tell warner brothers hey i want to use henry
cavill superman so with all the craziness with
the big warner brothers buyout the big merger
that just happened in the new leadership like a
bunch of people up at the top of warner brothers
got fired they're bringing in a new kevin feige
type of figure to lead dc all of dc's brands not
just the movies but all the comic books the toys
everything there's so much upheaval this is
like the best shot for henry cavill actually
coming back as superman he has a way better shot
now than he did last year apparently the new ceo
the company is a huge superman stand and wants
to make a much bigger deal of the character than
they've done in the past couple of years he's kind
of been languishing in the movie universe recently
so hopefully we'll hear something about a
brand new superman movie happening really soon
but what's gonna happen is we're gonna get a
brand new trailer later this week and it'll be
completely different footage of course i'll
do a new video for what'll probably happen
because they're going to drop it on wednesday and
there'll be a couple other big episode videos that
i'll be doing i'll probably put out my black adam
trailer video first then i'll do my obi-wan kenobi
episode 4 video and then my miss marvel video
will post after that because there's a running
marvel series that'll run with obi-wan kenobi
on wednesdays so just this wednesday is going to
be crazy so make sure you have alerts enable for
my channel so you don't miss any of those videos
i'll probably wind up having to wait till
thursday to release that marvel episode video
if you have any questions about the character or
anything that i didn't cover in this video just
let me know in the comments and i'll try to add it
to my wednesday trailer video everyone click here
for the new flash movie trailer video and click
here for my obi wan kenobi episode 4 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!